Tariq Wally played High School football
at Canyon Springs High School when the
pandemic came and ended his as well as
others playing career and he was worried
he couldn't get a scholarship but when
Lincoln University called he was offered
a scholarship and his family was very
proud of that achievement he never gave
up and what he said he was going to do
he did he accomplished it he said he was
going to college he was going to play
football and he did Latoya McNair's son
Tyrique Watley had dreams that went
unfulfilled and tragically ended by a
straight bullet in Oakland the 18 year
old was killed on August 29 2021
investigators say Whatley was the
passenger in a car when someone on the
sidewalk began shooting two others in
another vehicle were also injured I
couldn't believe what I was hearing I
just sent him to college he was doing
great I was shocked heard and just so
disappointed more than a year later in
watley's Murder remains unsolved during
this holiday season his family says they
all get together and watley's presence
is missing he had a big smile they just
took something from us that we expected
I expected that more from uh to see more
out of him I did
and so we just want to know that they
took a really a bright light uh from the
world all the family wants now is
Justice and that can only happen with an
arrest they took something from us great
they took somebody
Who Loved life who was dedicated to his
souls and his dreams police and Oakland
crime suffers are offering a twenty
thousand dollar reward for any
information that leads to the shooter's
arrest reporting in The Newsroom Joshua
figuero eight news now